in the last video we were looking at
this particular function it's a very
non-linear function and we were
picturing it as a transformation that
takes every point x y in space to the
point x plus sine y y plus sine of x and
moreover we zoomed in on a specific
point and let me actually write down
what point we zoomed in on it was
negative 2 1. that's something we're
going to want to record here
negative 2
1
and i added a couple extra grid lines
around it just so we can see in detail
what the transformation does to points
that are in a neighborhood of that point
and over here this square shows the
zoomed in version of that neighborhood
and what we saw was that even though the
function as a whole as a transformation
looks rather complicated around that one
point
it looks like a linear function it's
locally linear so what i'll show you
here is what matrix is going to tell you
the linear function that this looks like
and this is going to be some kind of two
by two matrix i'll make a lot of room
for ourselves here it'll be a 2x2 matrix
and the way to think about it is to
first go back to our original setup
before the transformation and think of
just a tiny step to the right what i'm
going to think of as a little partial x
a tiny step in the x direction and what
that turns into after the transformation
is going to be some tiny step in the
output space and here let me actually
kind of draw on what that tiny step
turned into it's no longer purely in the
x direction it has some rightward
component but now also some downward
component
and to be able to represent this in a
nice way what i'm going to do is instead
of writing the entire function as
something with a vector valued output
i'm going to go ahead and represent this
as a
two separate scalar valued functions i'm
going to write the scalar value
functions
f1
of xy
so i'm just giving a name to x plus sign
y
and f2 of xy
again all i'm doing is giving a name to
the functions we already have written
down
is when i look at this vector the
consequence of taking a tiny dx step in
the input space
that corresponds to some 2d movement in
the output space and the x component of
that movement right if i was going to
draw this out and say hey what's the x
component of that movement
that's something we think of as a little
partial change in f1
the x component of our output and if we
divide this if we take you know partial
f1 divided by the size of that initial
tiny change it basically scales it up to
be a normal sized vector not a tiny
nudge but something that's more constant
that doesn't shrink as we zoom in
further and further and then similarly
the change in the y direction right the
vertical component of that step that was
still caused by the dx right it's still
caused by that initial step to the right
that is going to be
the tiny partial change in f2 the y
component of the output because here
we're all just looking in the output
space that was caused
by a partial change in the x direction
and again i kind of like to think about
this we're dividing by a tiny amount
this partial f2 is really a tiny tiny
nudge but by dividing by the size of the
initial tiny nudge that caused it we're
getting something that's basically a
number something that doesn't shrink
when we consider more and more zoomed in
versions
so that that's all what happens when we
take a tiny step in the x direction
but another thing you could do another
thing you can consider
is a tiny step in the y direction right
is we want to know hey if you take a
single step some tiny unit upward
what does that turn into after the
transformation
and what that looks like
what that looks like is this vector that
still has some upward component but it
also has a rightward component
and now i'm going to write its
components as the second column of the
matrix because as we know when you're
representing a linear transformation
with a matrix the first column tells you
where the first basis vector goes and
the second column shows where the second
basis vector goes
if that feels unfamiliar either check
out the refresher video or maybe go and
look at some of the linear algebra
content
but to figure out the coordinates of
this guy we do basically the same thing
we say first of all the change in the x
direction here
the x component of this nudge vector
that's going to be given
as a partial change to f1 right to the x
component of the output here we're
looking in the output space so we're
dealing with f1 f1 and f2
and we're asking what that change was
that was caused by a tiny change in the
y direction
so the change in f1 caused by some tiny
step in the y direction divided by the
size of that tiny step
and then the y component of our output
here
the y component of the step in the
output space that was caused by the
initial tiny step upward in the input
space
well that
is the change of f2
second component of our output as caused
by dy as caused by that little
partial y
and of course all of this is very
specific to the point that we started at
right we started at the point negative 2
1. so each of these partial derivatives
is something that really we're saying
don't take the function evaluate it at
the point two negative one and when you
evaluate each one of these at the point
two negative one you'll get some number
and that'll give you a very concrete two
by two matrix that's gonna represent the
linear transformation that this guy
looks like once you've zoomed in
so this matrix here that's full of all
of the different partial derivatives has
a very special name it's called as you
may have guessed the jacobian
or more fully you'd call it the jacobian
matrix and one way to think about it is
that it carries all of the partial
differential information right it's
taking into account both of these
components of the output and both
possible inputs and giving you kind of a
grid of what all the partial derivatives
are but as i hope you see it's much more
than just a way of recording what all
the partial derivatives are there's a
reason for organizing it like this in
particular and it really does come down
to this idea of local linearity if you
understand that the jacobian matrix is
fundamentally supposed to represent
what a transformation looks like when
you zoom in near a specific point almost
everything else about it will start to
fall in place
and in the next video i'll go ahead and
actually compute this just to show you
what the process looks like and how the
result we get kind of matches with the
picture we're looking at see you then